minister representing the government
this morning paul scully is with us good
morning thank you for joining us um the
former chief whip the man responsible
for making sure that back benchers did
what they were supposed to do and
support boris johnson is now saying that
boris johnson is not worthy of the
office of prime minister why do you
think he is
uh no i respect mark harper's
views on this and other other um uh
backbenchers that have taken their come
to their own conclusions the prime
minister has uh made a full statement
yesterday he
made a full apology yesterday as well he
was under the belief uh at that time
that uh that
what he did was it acceptable in terms
of he was with the same people that he
was going to be within in the meeting
afterwards um and was probably working
with before but nonetheless the police
have um uh have come to that different
conclusion he absolutely respects that
and i think it's the right thing to do
for him to make that apology to pay the
fine and then get get back to the day
job those really important issues okay
at the moment here's the thing then what
if he's so confident that he's you know
doing the right thing why doesn't he
allow the um privileges committee
to decide whether or not he has broken
any rules why doesn't he just say full
disclosure you can look at whatever you
like well i think there's a number of um
procedures in place at the moment in
terms of the met police investigation is
still going on because there's other
events being investigated sue grey has
been charged with uh publishing the full
report uh the the after having done her
interim report a few weeks ago and so
there's a number of um uh streams of
process already in in in action but
we'll see what happens with the motion
why doesn't he allow his colleagues to
look at somewhere if he's got nothing to
hide why not allow them well they they
will be able to see that with you know
from that sue grey report they'll see
that they'll see all the detail there
rather than setting up a third strand of
investigation but we'll see what happens
at um uh tomorrow in the uh in the
debate in parliament tomorrow is it
because uh uh as according to jacob
jacob reese mogger should say that the
privilege
i'll say that again the privileges
committee is a distinguished body but
it's chaired by a labour party
politician i'd bear that
in mind what does he mean by that i
don't know if that's not that's
certainly not the you know the he
doesn't have a point well that's not the
view that i take i mean the the point is
as i say there is a number of strands of
uh
uh investigation into this whole
situation and rather than start another
strand at this point in time i think we
need to exhaust those those processes
yesterday he was at the dispatch box and
he apologized and he apologized and he
apologized i think 30 times something
like that but only about one incident
and he's only been fined for one
incident at the moment but as we all
know he's being
investigated for six
separate events how many times
does a prime minister have to break the
law before he has to step down i think
well first of all i can't speculate on
the investigation that's carried on
because
i know that but i think that what we
need to do is look at each of those
events in the round there may be
different circumstances there may not be
i don't know there may be the similar
there's a similar uh view similar
defense that the prime minister's taking
in terms of the the he believed it was
within the workplace situation
with the same people that he was
literally just heading to a meeting in
minutes afterwards um but we'll have to
say that's why it's difficult to
speculate at this point okay well let's
look at the may 10 event specifically
then 100 people were invited to bring
their own booze
and the invite was from the pm's private
secretary martin reynolds i think we can
actually look at that invite
and then the prime minister said on the
12th of january
that um
he didn't really
realize that when he was there that it
was some sort of party and he was there
for about 20 minutes in the garden 100
people had been invited to come along
and bring their own boos
um and then he said subsequently he
thought that probably on reflection that
he should have told people to go back
inside um are you slightly anxious that
that could lead to another breach of the
law by the prime minister well i'm just
anxious that we get to the end of this
and we actually see all of the
information out uh in the whole i mean
martin reynolds has clearly gone from
number 10 now uh because i'm going to
stay
no no but this is a different situation
in terms of the fact that martin
reynolds actually went out and actively
invited people into it do you think he
did that without the prime minister
knowing um he could easily have done
that but but i don't know um you know
this is his private secretary and he
would have sent out an invite to 100
people to party in the garden of number
10 with booze during the lockdown when
nobody else was allowed to meet even
outside apart from with one other person
and the prime minister wouldn't have
known well i know my private sector does
things without me now
i don't know this is all speculation so
i can't you're not throwing your
privates actually under the bus there no
no absolutely because they you know
i'm not talking about drinks but i'm
clearly i do not sit and do the job of
my private sector otherwise there's no
point having a private sector in the
middle of lockdown and a hundred people
invited to bring their own booze in his
back garden yeah
and he was there for 20 minutes what i'm
saying what i'm saying is that what i'm
saying is that this invitation is is not
acceptable because clearly bringing
other people in from outside i don't
think that was the different from the
situation we were just talking about
when the prime minister was just
literally heading to a meeting uh but
unless this is why speculation isn't
particularly helpful because until we've
got all of the information in front of
us then we can make a dis
informed decision about it at the moment
we're just going around the houses
speculating okay but the prime minister
knew that he was in the garden obviously
he knew that he'd been in the cabinet
room and there had been cake there and
people including his interior designer
or decorator as we would call them in
wigan were there as well and yet he then
also was potentially at four other
events that he's been linked to and then
he said this on the first of december if
you'll bear with me in the house of
commons at the dispatch mr speaker
what i can tell the right honorable
gentleman is that
is that all guidance was followed uh
completely during number ten i have been
repeatedly assured since these
allegations emerged
that there was no party
and that
and that no kovid rules were broken and
that is what i have been repeatedly
assured
so that suggests that the prime minister
uh has been informed as you see this the
second thing that he's been informed
okay fine these are people in the
workplace but in mind there's about 400
people working downing street it's a
it's a workplace it's not um just the
home of the prime minister the home of
the chancellor um and so there are a lot
of people around there all the time now
clearly where the investigation uh is
looking at why the police um would have
uh
found a contravention is because the
fact that there were
food alcohol these kind of things are
involved in that but that's why we need
but the prime minister at the time when
he spoke in parliament said
i believed this was actually a workplace
gathering um
he's now said that the police have
because they found otherwise in that
particular event that we're just
discussing um he respects that decision
um and has paid the fine i don't know
what he's saying i don't know what
you're trying to tell me though well
what i'm trying to say that the prime
minister had advice he just said he just
said that that um uh he was told that he
believed all guidance was followed he
thought all guidance was followed now
the police in the event that they've
investigated to date
have said no
that wasn't the case he's accepted that
um that decision from the police he's
paid the fine um and and then he's
moving on does he accept that he broke
the law
he's accepted that the police have come
up with a different conclusion to where
where he where he um uh
uh what he thought thought at the time
does he accept he broke the law though
except the police have found him to have
broken the law yeah but does he accept
well i don't know i mean again it's
speculation because i haven't spoken to
him about it
do you accept that he broke the law um
well the police have found that because
the only other way of doing it is to go
to a court and contest the fixed penalty
notice and frankly that's just not not
that you know the system that we have
about fixed penalty notices that's not
really appropriate so given that you
accept that he broke the law why can you
still support him why can't why can a
sitting prime minister who is a law
breaker be a lawmaker because it's a you
know you you're opening the the prime
minister interpreted what he helped with
at the time of the law the guidance at
the time um and so and and that's what
he did he take it he took his decision
in the heat of the moment but he's
accepted he's done wrong he's accepted
he's made a mistake he said and he he's
made a full apology 30 times as you as
you say yesterday in his um statement i
don't think anyone could really see that
he didn't think that he wasn't contrite
i mean
he either didn't know what the law was
which is not acceptable or he broke the
law which is not acceptable well
the times reported that the the the
party that he was fight for the day
afterwards
no no but i'm saying so different so the
media who were covering at the time
didn't think anything of it they
probably didn't know about the other 16
events that weren't maybe not but
actually
the one we're talking about whether he
he knew he was breaking the law well the
newspapers didn't really seem to worry
about the fact that he broke the law so
at the time we it's difficult to look at
hindsight about someone's mind what
someone was thinking about two years ago
when we are looking something that
journalists have better judgment than
the police then i'm saying that that
that was the prevailing view at the time
was that the prime minister's birthday
he had a few minutes of respite that was
a prevailing view at the time as
reported in the newspapers but we're now
looking at with a very different lens
because of the situations that that's
come up and
that's what builds up to that uh that
anger that frustration that i know
people are feeling but that's why the
prime minister was right to accept the
fixed penalty notice to pay the fine to
apologize fully to parliament yesterday
on a number of occasions and then to
move on okay let's just have a look at
what the ministerial code says here we
go ministers who knowingly mislead
parliament would be expected to offer
their resignation to the prime minister
and of course he wrote the forward for
that as well you're saying he didn't i'm
saying what should happen
if a minister breaks the code
should they resign
if the minute if someone breaks the
ministerial code then yeah that's that's
the um expected thing to do absolutely
the right thing but what you what you're
quoting there is that you knowingly
misled parliament that's exactly what
i'm pointing at and i've just
i've just explained that in my in my
opinion for all the reasons that i've
said i don't believe he did knowingly
mislead party yeah you see i want to put
this in my back pocket for when you come
back in a month's time and he's got more
convictions and then we talk we remind
ourselves again about what that's right
no put it put in your back pocket
because as i say this is why it's
difficult to speculate because what
we're after what i'm after what every um
mp is after is the whole
information because we come on day in
day out to speak to you to speak to um
other other new colleagues and really
happy to do so
um with not all of the information and
that's part of the media
okay so that's interesting so you are as
frustrated as everybody else is in the
country to try to get to the bottom of
what happened
i want the sugray report so that we can
see everything uh i want to make sure
that that police can get to there and
the investigation so we can finish that
part of it and then we can and then we
can probably move on because there's so
many issues um yep
and you um
presumably think that it's nonsense to
compare breaking a rule that you make
yourself when 120 000 people have died
and the country was in lockdown for many
many weeks to
receiving a parking fine for parking on
a double yellow line i think if you put
them to put the two together is it
difficult to make a comparison i think
what brandon lewis is saying yesterday
was the process is actually very similar
in terms of the fact that uh you're not
technically found guilty you're
technically not convicted because that's
done in a ju
in a court not by the police the police
enforce the law and so that's i think
the point that brandon was making rather
than actually just the juxtaposition of
parking and a covert transgression okay
thanks for clarifying that appreciate uh
talking to you this morning thank you
for joining us much appreciated